bonsoir bonsoir taco et sérieusement
furieux pourquoi thierry ardisson parce
que je me lève violemment duo de mai 1 m
78 concept rats appellation la fin du
monde à fin du monde c'est dans cinq
milliards d'années à son travail quand
le sait va devenir une géante rouge
champagne
mesdames messieurs
méningite le 11 août dans 5 milliards
d'années
la possibilité de destruction de paris
cette année d'accord j'allais parler au
mythe dans toutes les prophéties sait
que paris ait comparé aux non
on est cool bon d'accord excusez-moi pas
qu'au premier la première boule à une
question dont tu commencé pourquoi vous
êtes toujours habillés en noir je
comprends pas faire dans la vie passée
j'étais curé j'ai conservé ce goût du
noir ce goût de la soutane ancien c'est
quand vous étiez dissimule les formes
avec c'est moi aussi
au départ c'était pour être sûr qu'on me
reconnaisse puis maintenant c'est pour
dissimuler les formes bien alors bailly
sylvie rey pas s'ils voulaient être sûrs
qu'on reconnaisse
[Rires]
alors on va parler de mode clip qui
s'appelle 1999 le ciel le feu du ciel
chez michel lafon mais avant j'aimerais
qu'on parle de vous parce qu'on vous
vend souvent dans des émissions de
télévision et je suis sûr que les jeunes
générations ne savent pas ce que vous
avez fait avance vous apporter à la mode
et on va quand même en parler un petit
peu serge si vous pouviez basculer la
lumière
tu attends cosy c'est bien alors vous
êtes né en 1934 à san sebastien votre
père était militaire
votre père a été fusillé par fait partie
des dix sept militaires fusillé par
franco à la prison de san antonio au
pays basque où là à ce moment là vous
êtes venu en france à l'âge de 5 ans
avec une concentration importante
argelès et ensuite caché par tanguy
prigent à ministre socialiste en
bretagne au péril de sa vie puisque ma
mère était recherché par la gestapo oui
alors ce que je comprends pas très bien
c'est que votre père a été fusillé par
franco et vous avez pourtant accepté
d'être décoré cet officier de l'ordre
d'isabelle la catholique par le roi
d'espagne est pas la même chose
d'affronter j'ai toujours refusé d'aller
en espagne invité par le général franco
pour des bonnes raisons parce que ma
mère était encore vivante et je pouvais
pas aller dans le haut-pays de
l'assassin de mon père ouais mais le roi
d'espagne pour considérer que maintenant
tout le monde carlos est un roi c'est un
endroit fabuleux extraordinaire de j'ai
pour lui un énorme respect on est
d'accord pas qu on est d'accord dix mois
dites moi pendant donc votre vous à
paris à 20 ans vous faites les choses
pour faire l'architecturé moins cher
chirac gmail architecture payer vos
études vous commencez par vente des
boutons à balancier haga puis des
accessoires les accessoires à tous les
couturiers que soit ce qu apparaît libre
ndiaga grimonet enchaîné tas de gens qui
ont disparu aujourd'hui alors un jour
vous faites un défilé de mode c'est pour
ça que je voulais en parler parce que je
ne sais pas si les jeunes générations
sont au courant qu'ils s'appellent 12
robe 1 et alors là pour la première fois
parce qu'il faut bien dire c'est vous
qui l'avez fait pour la première fois
pour la première fois on voit des robes
en plastique enfin matières plastiques
en papier en cuir c'est une révolution
parce qu'elle est pas que ça il ya eu
aussi vous avez fait défiler les
premières filles noires
les dettes de les aider quand j'ai fait
défiler ses coutures vous avez rédigé à
cause de ça les américaines de nouveau
la fille de vogue et 2 passes 2 ans
m'ont craché au visage ouais c'était
avant dans time ou du coup pourquoi vous
prenez ses fils a indiqué pascal sur les
plus belles du monde ouais écharpe que
mon crash ou alors il faut dire qu'à la
ligue 1 au milieu des années 60 c'était
l'an 60 cup oui c'est à 64 gb je voulais
je voulais représenter la planète
entière et les femmes n'ont été des plus
belles de les peuples et vous la verrez
c'est toujours les faits avant beaucoup
de gens donc avait lisette malidor qu'on
a connu et connaît ce domaine et marie
madeleine qui après a été avec jacques
brel cathy rosiers khatir aux ivoiriens
des deux tomes il a fallu attendre
saint-laurent bien des années plus tard
douze ans après là pour qu'on retrouve
une noire dans l'est dans les défilés
alors vous avez transformé ça vous avez
fait défiler des défis noir est aussi
avant faut savoir que dans les défilés
de mode y avait des aboyeurs qui annonce
et les canons c'est le modèle vous été
le premier à mettre de la musique dans
les défis et j'ai même beaucoup la
musique des beatles la musique des
stones c'était vraiment une époque
formidable des années 60 où il y avait
vraiment la musique faisait partie du
quotidien vous aviez déjà beaucoup de
fins déjà à l'époque vous aviez même
genre d'idée que maintenant parce qu'on
71 vous disiez avec l'ère du verseau les
gens vont se dénuder c'est en 61 ans nom
et depuis effectivement là la mode val
de plus en plus vers le nu quand même
non non non ce nous sommes entrés dans
l'ère du verseau 94 nous allons revenir
maintenant pour une mode différent où il
n'y aura pas cette espèce de de nudité
trop flagrantes parce qu'elle ne trouve
que dans le jeu de l'amour dans le jeu
de l'est de l'érotisme il vaut mieux
suggérer que montrer bien sûr un titre
reid c'est plus joli quand on quand on
voit quelqu'un à billets et qu'on puisse
suggérer une certaine essentielle
l'imaginaire est très important dans la
vie de l'ère du verseau un lien direct
moi j'aime bien leur du verso des
îles l'ère du verseau est là pour 2600
ans ouais donc il vaut mieux de
s'habituer mais c'était alors vous
publiez un livre un jour chez laffont
90g la victoire j'avais 60 ans 67 tenu
ce
cette recherche ésotérique que j'ai
commencé à l'âge de 6 ans de septembre
pardon à 7 ans j'ai commencé à sortir de
mon corps à faire des voyages astraux
mais c'est une chose que ma grand mère
était une magicienne me disais mon mari
me disait t'es tu es toi n'en parle pas
regardez réaction de ta mère c'est
reconnaît me disait que j'étais je
devenais fou et donc j'ai continué à
travailler en temps me thézan et quand
je suis arrivé à 60 ans je me suis dit
bon basse thomas maintenant fait la fin
de ma vie je vais porter témoignage
voilà alors dans ce livre qui s'est
vendu à un million d'exemplaires
je veux dire aux trajectoires vous
parlez d'un coup de langue de louis de
l'ère du verseau la réincarnation de vos
vies antérieures c'est là que tout le
monde a découvert que vous aviez été
grand prêtre à hatem lors de
l'assassinât toutankhamon oui j'étais le
prêtre qui enseignait la cause bourgogne
égyptienne à aménophis iv 2 qu'est
devenu ensuite akhenaton est un jeune
prince égyptien qui s'appelait aussi c
est qu un jour akhenaton allait appeler
sauvé des eaux bonjour comment vous
savez ça parce que je le sais parce que
je donne mes voyages astraux la roma
tout appris mais la prochaine fois
ramenez-nous un truc
lors au cci matériel et des choses et
des flashs de
désinformation qui disent qu'ils sont
virtuelles qu'on ne peut pas ramener son
s'ingénia remarqué aux récits de rang à
caen j'ai dit il y a de cela 40 50
puisque dans mon atelier d'architecturé
auguste perret il y avait les plus
grands égyptologue était là comme
clément robichon qui aujourd'hui 90 ans
et qui fait autorité là-bas à louxor
quand j'ai dit que j'étais le prêtre qui
avait assassiné tout en clamant il m'a
dit mais tout temps comme on n'a jamais
être assassiné
il est il est mort de sa belle mort j'ai
dit non il a été assassiné et c'est à 10
ans que les égyptologues américains ont
découvert qu'ils avaient assassiné que
je lui avais défoncé le crâne vous oui
bien sûr c'est pourquoi il ya trois ans
et
regardent formation continue dans ce
livre dans ce livre donc dans le vif
trajectoire vous disiez aussi vous aviez
été une prostituée une jeune prostituée
du temps nous j'ai ainsi enlevé par les
dragons du roi a mené à ce lieu de
plaisir qui s'appelait le parc aux cerfs
viendra des champs elysées et j'ai servi
de chair fraîche au rouet du roi et à la
lui 15 balladur sympa comme bon alors en
fait vous êtes vous êtes batignolles en
tout cas parce que je trouve que vu le
prix que ça coûte de faire des voyages
astraux avec des vraies fusées tout ça
mais ça lui coûte pas un rond non après
tout ils emmerdent personnes s'est
envolé ce faire il ya tant de raisons
c'est en fait en fait ça nous coûte rien
ah non non jusque là en fait vous êtes
basque et vous descendez des atlantes
fabrice nous de l'une des plus vieilles
robes nous expliquer les cendres des
autres explique et l'unicité du peuple
base par le fait qu'ils descendent des
attentes vers l'assemblée myint oui
comme l'agent qui dirait un continent
qui était au mieux notion atlantique
quoi dites que vous êtes une vieille âme
réincarner garder ou non il s'agit de
surfer panel mes souvenirs remontent de
plus loin il ya 78 mille ans oui si vous
êtes venus ici sur terre il ya 78 ans en
2001 venant de la consommation de lait
chaque pas ça c'est pas mal mais j'ai
des secrets en revenant david a vraiment
de 2,7 soleil bleu en fin de cette
étoile bleue qui s'appelle altaïr nous
étions venus commencer une civilisation
ordonné dans ce monde planètes
terrestres ou les cromagnons avait
réussi à détruire les néandertaliens qui
étaient des animaux ou des humanoïdes un
peu lent frustrés et nous sommes venus
ici pour leur apporter une une
civilisation et un ordre si on me
demande de faire un résumé je peux pas
là
jeune homme pressé
il paraît que vous ramenez un truc ou
tard j'ai déconné en disant que c'est
pourquoi vous nous ramenez pas quelque
chose mais il paraît que dans chaque vie
il reste une forme d'oreille enfin voilà
il ya des souvenirs qu'ils veulent ça
mais vous vous même vous les avez
parfois vous aller dans un pays tiers
est moins
avantageux dire que dans un besoin dans
un pays dans un lieu est brusquement
celui vous le reconnaissez vous dire que
je suis bien de ce lieu très derrière ça
va se passer comme ça comme ça où vous
rencontrez un être et c'est tête vous
êtes un différend vous n'avez pas connu
ou à naître bruce quand vous êtes
attirés vers cet homme vers cette femme
vers ce vieillard et d'une façon
irrésistible complètement illogique
parce que il a été très proche de vous
dans une vie passée à vous expliquer le
déjà vu ce qu'on appelle le dg je veux
bien antérieure mais bien sûr c'est ce
que j'étais passé quand j'explique les
choses aussi un bon coup du chêne a
aussi indiqué ce témoin du temps je n'ai
pas vécu cette union parce que moi
j'étais bon nyon qui est bouddhiste au
viiie siècle au japon devra aller sans
pas que
ces contraintes et celle inverse ont été
toilettées quoi tirer avant c'est un
officier
austro-hongrois ans s'écoulent entre
1800 et 15 par l'âge et a comme celui-ci
alors non aimez vous avez lutté contre
napoléon 1er mai sur pattes heures oui
en aparté alors dites moi il ya un truc
quand même pas demander ce que je t'aime
je veux pas savoir jeudi de joie
vous l'avez cherché non alors là pas qu
il ya un truc quand même s'est dit plus
tard
quand vous êtes parti d'allah il ya donc
78 mille ans vous étiez en train de
faire l'amour faisais pas l'amour sur
altaïr mais vous étiez dans le
noir on est des épisodes des humanoïdes
j'étais un homme dans chéri on ne
faisait quand même l'amour quand vous
êtes père bien sûr nous étions bien sûr
quand vous a envoyé sur la pierre du
champ de faim entre un gouvernement et
c'est pour ça que vous avez déclaré la
baise m'a toujours dégoûté c'est à dire
parce que c'est parce que vous avez vu
ce qu ils tuent s'est interrompue sur
html 78 vous connais vous ces
informations je sais pas moi j'étais un
grand b d'heure quand j'étais jeune
baboo alors attendez vous avez été vous
dit que vous avez été plus haut jusqu'à
l'âge de 30 ans
je dis ça
je sais pas moi je n'ai pas inventé oui
mais moi je lis tous les jours dans la
presse des trucs hallucinants voit par
exemple que j'ai annoncé la fin du monde
oui d'accord c'est énorme ou alors que
j'ai payé des billets de train tout mais
ouvrière pour qu'elles partent en juin
oui en juin je fais ma collection oui je
l'année le réseau le 11 août la maison
paco rabanne intérêt qu elle attendait
si j'ai bien compris c'est un trou dans
la terre et
non si j'appelais jugé jeudi comment
j'ai vu comment la première fois que
j'ai baisé
le coq deux premiers c'était j'avais 9
ans à 12 ans dans bretagne profonde a
morlaix à morlaix j'avais une envie déjà
rien faire la morale est qu on a 12 ans
à l'époque il m'avait passé télémistes
télévision permis si tous ces écrits etc
eh bien j'ai fait un trou dans la terre
et j'ai joué j'ai baisé le sol j'ai voué
au moment où ge puis à des vieilles
toner à ces défis du monde
laurent
préparer sérieusement ici si on l'armée
jouit il ya eu un tremblement de terre
sainte et religieux frémissent man et il
ya eu intention rive nord je vais bien
il y a eu un flash blanc de lumière et
les parfums de bruit hier d'âge ont
bon goût at-elle
continué on y vrai et je raconte
simplement les choses telles qu'elles
sont passées puisque nous sommes venus
vous croire notre talent permissivité on
peut tout dire bientôt il sauf que dans
vous vous vous dites aujourd'hui je m'en
fou j'étais plutôt des
petites journées officiellement j'étais
persuadé pas gardien de but
le ballon
vous n'avez pas été plus haut jusqu'à
l'âge de 30 ans
déjà
alors votre vie votre vie actuelle paco
votre vie actuelle est la dernière avant
votre retour sur altaïr ça c'est vrai
nous elle c'est l'incarnation terrestre
et la dernière puisque j'ai accompli
tout ce tous les cycles bon je suis
douté de vous le savez pas mais laisse
ici je connais la théorie ainsi que
c'est un temps de temps la moitié d'un
temps pendant tes crise lorsqu'il
viendra il règnera un temps de temps la
moitié des teintes en un temps et en un
mois pour lui donc ça fera quarante sept
mois et moi c'était un temps de temps la
moitié d'un temps c'est-à-dire 78 milan
puisque le soleil mais soit 25 25 mille
années à faire le tour des 12 signes sur
logique mais il c'est une question de
connaissance le savoir vous êtes à
savoir perdu à savoir une juste dont je
suis parti à lacq est à la quête de ce
savoir quand j'avais 7 ans
très bien alors justement justement
tacot votre grand-mère était médium
quand même faut le dire elle nous a dit
[Rires]
non on va y arriver air était médium
malgré son de sa dialectique marxiste
était marxiste ma mère ouais elle était
médium
analystes et médias les médias mais ma
grand mère dont celui du coup une grande
magicienne oui elle m'a appris les le
secret de l'eau le secret du slameur que
verallia m'apprenait à tuer elle nous a
dit c'est toi qui a reçu le don de la
famille saoud sony adrien dont qui se
transmet du géant suisse que votre mère
ne voulait pas elle voulait pas
l'assumer parce qu'effectivement elle
était marxiste que vous venez de le dire
mais votre mère vous voulez vous appelez
rue ben ouais et dit tout ce que c'est
ruben rubens et la relaxe maintenant je
suis important la porte du verso de
porte devient ce que jérusalem mais oui
donc c'est passé des signes tout ça
maintient
alors le livre s'appelle 1999 le feu du
ciel donc je le montre voilà la caméra
comme on fait à la télévision c'est mon
huitième boucle c'est votre huitième
bouquin c'est chez michel lafon et ceci
a que là parce que sinon avant j'étais
jamais plus jamais à maintenant et
j'ai pendant deux ans j'ai voulu faire
ce bouquin parce que c'est une
division racontez nous la voyons donné
comme vous aviez 17% quand j'avais 17
ans je suis venu à paris pour moi ce
fait aux beaux-arts à l'atelier de vue
d'auguste perret enfin l'architecturé et
quand je me promenais dans les rues de
paris j'étais au blue est obligé de me
boucher les oreilles car j'entendais les
hurlements des gens qui ce qui brûle est
vive dans les rues et je voyais des gens
puisque nous étions quai malaquais aux
beaux-arts se jeter dans la seine il
continue à brûler dans l'eau et ce truc
me perturbait j'étais obligé de me
boucher les oreilles et cette vision m'a
poursuivi très longtemps et quand j'ai
commencé à étudier toutes les prophéties
qui depuis le quatrième siècle que ce
soixante odile
tout tout tout y en a des milliers des
centaines tout part de cette éventualité
de paris un jour brûlures à il ya deux
ans j'ai réalisé que ça y est maintenant
aide il ya deux ans comme je le disais
nous de mu depuis 45 ans possiblement le
seul musée entièrement ouvert les façon
très simple or il y a deux personnes qui
donnent le parce qu'on sait que paris un
jour périra dans les flammes c'est dans
toutes les prophéties où on ne sait pas
quand car c'est un interdire de ne pas
savoir or il ya deux personnes qui
donnent des dates c'est nostradamus dans
le fameux 4 1 % en 1999 dit voilà on y
va d'ailleurs c'est la dixième century
ne sera la luz dit du ciel viendra
rendre à des filières des frayeurs en
1999 c'est donc la seule date que donne
nostradamus toutes ces prophéties et il
ya une voyante de la fraude et marie
julie jean denis extraordinaire et qui
est morte en 1946 qui dit avant la
sienne la fin du siècle à paris brûlera
et ça sera pendant d'une journée obscur
weekly l'équipe soleil alors moi j'ai
cherché je me suis dit qu'est ce que ça
peut être je serai pas la réponse et aux
autres non mais moi je croyais au début
c'est qu'un astéroïde géant ouais allait
venir frapper paris oui et que la ville
était détruite et dans un an il ya deux
ans dans une conférence que jeunes et en
province 1 il était chercheur du cnrs
m'a dit monsieur rabat nous avons
répertorié tous les objets célestes
rien ne viendra frapper la terre en 99
même dit il c'était il ya deux ans
j'étais pas au courant me dit la station
mir est un très bon visiteurs
actuellement les c'était il ya deux ans
elle descend de plus en plus en orbite
basse et nous pensons qu'elle elle
s'abîme rassurent l'acteur en 99 je dis
ça ou ça il me dit dans l'océan
pacifique sur les médias disent parle
toujours de vendre sa météo les océans
pacifique oui et moi je l'aimé bien est
ce qu'il y ait une orbite qui passe au
dessus de paris dim dit oui une orbite
de qui passe au dessus paris et il me
dit c'est lui qui me dit et nous savons
qu'il ya du plutonium à l'intérieur et
oxyde de plus thomas jane et là j'ai eu
un flash et vu cette bombe voilà vous
avez vu cette mesure mais j'ai tous les
fermiers qu'adamu se sont ouverts vous
dites que donc ce que vous dites c'est
qu'il y aura suite à l'équipe non mais
vous avez posé une question mais je veux
bien que ce soit clair pour tout le
monde dit que c'est pas évident ensuite
deux éclipses voilà il ya une éclipse de
20 tués attendez attendez attendez les
28 juillet là on fait la lune là on fait
la théorie de takuya une éclipse le 28
juillet juillet et qui faisait une
première deuxième et clip on vous dit
que les interférences magnétiques créé
par ces éclipses vont faire tomber le 11
août 1999 à 11h 22h22 22 h abbaye de
simiesque voilà la cimiez il y à une
fraise énorme qui date du xviie siècle
et y est tu connaîtras leur de ta mort
mais pas le jour et on voit l'église de
soleil dessiner une horloge qui est
arrêté à hans landa 22 alors ce que vous
dites c'est que là en fait la station
mir aujourd'hui est une station
soviétique enfin russe désormais c'est
une bombe atomique sur orbite qui à peu
près la puissance de 1000 hiroshima
c'est ça ben écoutez mire été conçu par
monsieur prince 9 qui n'est pas un
tendre n'ya rigolo et quand il a lancé
mou mais que mir c'est le court comme
chef que l'enseignant mais c'était de
l'objet de brejnev reggane à la lancer
sa fameuse guerre des étoiles a dit si
les russes de lance d engin contenant
des bombes atomiques nous nous allons
lancer des engins tueur de cette étude
réalisée alors c'est pas moi qui le dit
ce qu'avance une question ils vont vous
lui posez une question mais je suis
perdu un homme est basse qui suivent
le cinéma j'attends bien j'attends bien
non mais je suis perdue parce que ça
peut voir des concerts des conséquences
incroyable que vous nous racontez nano
et si messi a des absences équipes
réseau
et allez j'en suis pas vous croire mais
je ne crois pas et 17,1 à lui mais on ne
veut mourir les voyants sont faits pour
être allumées non mais c'est très récent
et très lumineux ou pas c'est vrai qu'il
ya des gens qui veulent avant des
réactions vaches non violence est
justement justement de 500 jeux je m'y
attendais je m'y attendais je pensais
vous dire une chose quand j'ai voulu
m'arrêter de parler en 94 j'ai dit j'ai
été voir une jeune femme le sim attiser
une nonne et la vierge nous est apparue
la vierge lui a dit dit à mon fils
bien-aimé paco rabanne que surtout ils
n'arrêtent pas de parler nous voulons
qu'il continue de parler qui ne
craignent rien de là où nous le
protégerons or moi quand j'ai créé ce
bouquin je me à 16 suffisamment de cons
dans paris il ya suffisamment de dingue
je vais recevoir des lettres de dingue
je vais recevoir d'aidé des crachats des
injures mes enfants à ma grande surprise
je reçois des lettres actuellement
jeunes et tout ça sur mon gros fabuleuse
l'aide merci de voir tant d astrid et
c'est la connerie comme un truc quand
vous avez écrit ça c'était de voir votre
éditeur inquiet michel lafon et qui vous
a dit tu peux pas écrire ça c'est pas
bon signe a dit que j'ai déjà pratiqué à
ramener chez lafuma publié moi aussi
d'ailleurs tu bois de l'argent michel
les goûts et vous vous dites à ce moment
là j'ai deux solutions soit je me tais
et je perds le sommeil et je deviens fou
ça j'en trouvais ça mais soit je parle
et je risque de passer pour un fou cela
dit donc j'ai préféré être ridicule
disons à bien dormir fabien gilot est
engagé comme un peu les autres de dormir
mais ces mesures n'ont pas s'il veut
this it il est pas là le 11 août
viennent se passera c'est pas la
destruction de paris qui est important
je viens d'acheter un appareil
qui ont déjà au monsieur rabat c'est pas
possible monsieur ramadan des studios
mais cette fois je suis tu as mais bon
qu'est ce que je fais moi mais non ne
sais pas qu'est-ce que je fais là qui
sont souvent des lieux
j'ai fait une petite annonce immobilière
en vue de chute de satellites genre
superbe appartement m'attendais ya un
truc qui me l'a dit tout à l'heure c'est
que les prophéties était fait pourquoi
et coûtera rien alors est-ce que l'on
peut envoyer vous que j'ai fait ce bout
alors est-ce qu'on peut sauver je parle
plus et facebook pour que cela n'arrive
pas ça jusqu'aux qu'est ce qu'on peut
faire dans un journal du matin le figaro
pour ne pas le nommer il y à un mois et
demi c'est un article comme ça les
russes demandent aux américains qu'on
leur prête là c'est la navette atlantis
pour aller chercher quelque chose de
très important dans la station mir les
américains répondent attendait qu'est ce
que c'est que vous voulez monter le
russe ne répondent pas les américains
ont répondu c'est écrit noir sur blanc
nous ne pouvons pas vous prêtez la
navette atlantis lancer la navette
atlantis coûte 5 milliards de dollars et
que les gouvernements du monde dont 1,5
milliard de dollars aux russes comme ça
il démontré les gens prient astrid une
question familière aux russes vous
vendez l'appartement vannes oc
annonce et deux éclipses les études
prouvent qu'il y en a qu'une donc
je pense que j'ai bien compris votre
question on va y revenir après et il est
attendu des terminaux différents d'une
de lune le 28 juillet et ça c'est
scientifique hélas tout à l'heure le mon
contradicteur qui va venir là on n'a pas
géré rigole vous vous dira mais aussi
parce que moi les scientifiques qui me
disent que le nuage de tchernobyl
s'était arrêté aux frontières françaises
parce qu'il n'avait pas de visa et bien
moi je rigole quand même laissé des
traces bien
maintenant on a on va conclure pour
cette partie de votre immersion
dernière j'ai un ami puisque je connais
devait souvent en argentine vient de
m'appeler de woodside dans le nord de la
ménagère je dis pas les tests voilà bon
élément votre dock 1 un soyouz est tombé
en argentine au nord d'argentine il
contenait du plutonium mais cette tête
simplement moteur plutonium donc vous
voyez que c'est plus sympa alors on te
le gardes à voir avant en tous les cas
si vous n'êtes
pas comme vous dites qu'on va tous
mourir des romains ont déconné en
attendant quoi
booster français
et
astrid el bacha paris dont cet achat
sursaut pour vous dire est nommé par le
président maurice attendez attendez
attendez on rit on a on va on va en
rester là on va en rester là pour le
moment la seule chose dont j'ai parlé
s'est achevée devant
rester là on a medal messieurs jo et
astrid je sais où il travaillait le 11
août et vous avez raison de votre
carrière et nantes ont explosé
alors vous avez dit paco rabanne si je
me trompe je ne parlerai plus jamais de
prophétie plus donc vous le dit à la
télévision de sa séparation bourg
diffusera la bande jeu à chaque
interview non 178 millions bien sûr si
on ne demande pas la bombe c'est tout ça
que ce sera bien sûr au vu et au su de
tous le brouillard s'il n'arrive pas je
ferme ma gueule défini qui d'accord
puisque c'est pour le 11 août et puisque
tout va être détruit à paris le 11 août
est ce qu'on peut dire a fait de lancer
un appel à tous les parisiens attendent
et le 12 août pour acheter quoi que ce
soit chez paco rabanne
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous mettez un
pouce bleus